[Music]
foreign
so I'm really really excited about this
next sequence of lectures on the
numerical integration of ordinary
differential equations because this is
where we take a lot of what we have
learned so far and how to solve systems
of ordinary differential equations and
we kind of move this into much more real
world settings so we've talked about how
to solve linear coupled systems of first
order equations x dot equals ax and
really these are kind of valid near
linearizations near the fixed points or
equilibrium of General nonlinear systems
but we haven't talked too much about how
to handle a generic non-linear system of
equations x dot equals f of x where f is
a non-linear function okay and so you
know linear systems benefit from the
fact that linear superposition holds so
you can kind of break this down into
simpler sub problems like you can
diagonalize a and solve each of those
decoupled problems and then add those up
and and get Solutions there aren't uh
generic solution text like techniques
like that for x dot equals f of x for a
non-linear function f and in those cases
we often resort to numerical integration
so most of the systems we care about
like integrating uh you know predicting
the future of a weather system or an
epidemiological system or a fluid flow
system or even a very complicated
mechanical system typically we can't uh
you know we can't solve them using these
linear techniques and we have to resort
to numerical integration so that's what
I'm going to show you in this sequence
I'm going to walk you through kind of in
this lecture the overview and then we're
going to dive into some topics
so I'm going to talk a little bit more
about what I mean by this differential
equation x dot equals f of x
here x is typically a vector of the
state of my system it's a vector
representing the state of my system
representing
the state
of my system it's often called a state
Vector that's what it's called and f f
of x f is a function of X is generically
some non-linear function it may be a
non-linear function it may be a
non-linear function
a non-linear function
and it might even vary in time so I've
written x dot equals f of x where f is
kind of a constant it's just a function
of X that doesn't change in time but
this function could actually be evolving
and changing in time so that would be an
autonomous or a non-autonomous system
would be whether or not this does or
does not depend on time so we'll talk
about both of those actually and one of
the examples I like to give of this is
let's say that I have the fluid flow
like in the Gulf of Mexico something
like that so let's say I have you know
this is Florida this is the Gulf of
Mexico I'm from you know somewhere in
Texas over over here
and essentially what we have is some
some fluid velocity field sometimes we
call this a vector field
so we have some you know Vector field
I'm just going to draw kind of arrows
and making this up you know maybe
there is some area of big circulation
right that's uh not always a good thing
when that happens
um
okay so I've got some big Vector field
for the fluid flow in the Gulf of Mexico
and let's say I am lost at sea so I'm
like a little you know I'm on a life
raft or something and I am at this
initial condition uh X at time zero so I
not only have this differential equation
I also have some initial condition exit
time zero equals x naught
and what I might be interested in this
system is how to so so first off this
Vector field would be f of x it
literally says at every point in Space X
what is the vector the fluid velocity
field that is changing my position in
time so I assume that my particle kind
of advects or flows along with this you
know fluid velocity field and at every
point in space here at every point x
this is my function f of x okay is this
kind of vector field velocity field here
and you'll notice that in this example
this two-dimensional fluid flow my
function f has two components it has the
kind of velocity direction in the X
component and the velocity component in
the y in the y direction so here you
know f
of a point x
would have you know some uh kind of x
velocity
and some y velocity
component okay f of x would have some x
velocity and some y velocity component
I'm also going to say that this is not
just some function of X but it's also a
function of time so realistically I
actually should
um you know generically add in this um
possibility that my function my right
hand side ordinary differential equation
can be changing or evolving in time so
of course you know this flow velocity is
constantly evolving in the in the Gulf
of Mexico it's constantly changing in
time uh because you know the ocean is
churning and wind is blowing the surface
and changing things so this is actually
changing in time and these pink arrows
are actually going to be moving in time
themselves okay but what I really am
interested in is if I have some initial
condition X naught how can I predict
where that trajectory is going to go in
future times so can I actually this
that's what I mean by numerical
integration of Odes of an ordinary
differential equation is can I tell
where this trajectory is going to go in
the future
by stepping It Forward in kind of these
discrete
discrete kind of delta T advances in
time so if I know X naught can I predict
what it'll be you know one time step in
the future can I predict what x at time
one will be can I predict what x at time
two and exit time three and so on and so
forth can I predict a trajectory so
that's what we call a trajectory I'm
just going to write this down
so we say you know a trajectory
a trajectory
is a path
and I'm really going to say it's some
path X of T okay so it's some you know
it's some path
X of T so this is X of t
but numerically when I do this on a
computer when I solve this on a computer
what that is actually going to be often
is
um
discretized at discrete points in time
okay so I'm going to approximate this
continuous path with these discrete
points X at times 0 exit Time 1 exit
time two dot dot dot you know all the
way up to exit time time n and sometimes
if I drop my under bar here you know
these are still vectors of States so
please don't be confused if I forget an
underbar and so what I mean by a
trajectory is typically you know I have
some X naught and that's going to be
going to some X1 and that's going to be
going to some X2 dot dot dot all the way
to some X
n so that's what I mean by a trajectory
is a kind of either continuous or
discrete path of points in time where
x k is equal to X at some kth time
instance and oftentimes I'm going to say
that these are sampled at a at a
constant discrete delta T So TK my kth
time instant would actually be K delta T
time steps okay you don't have to take
constant time steps but usually in our
numerical integration schemes we're
going to be taking these constant time
steps we'll we'll cook up an algorithm
that will step the system forward that
will approximate this true trajectory at
these discrete time instances for this
differential equation and again I'm
going to reiterate the reason we need to
resort to numerical integration of these
non-linear ordinary differential
equations like finding a trajectory you
know evolving in the Gulf of Mexico is
because there is a fundamental limit to
what we can do with analytical
techniques with linear techniques with
pencil and paper techniques okay so in
really really big problems or in really
complicated problems you know these
linear techniques are only valid near
fixed points in neighborhoods of fixed
points typically and it might be really
hard to find these fixed points or hard
to analyze these for very high
dimensional systems okay and so we have
to resort to numerical integration for
most real world problems of Interest
uh okay so in this example you know I
might want to predict if I'm in some
life raft in the Gulf of Mexico someone
might want to predict based on my last
location where am I going to be a day
from now or two days from now or
something like that
you might also predict uh where was I
last seen you might actually integrate
this backward in time and figure out
okay well this is my last you know you
can integrate these trajectories
backwards in times sometimes and you
might do that to figure out where where
you came from okay where a particle or a
trajectory came from
uh integrating
um particles in the Gulf of Mexico you
know is also useful if there is a big
oil spill and you want to know where
this blob of oil is going to go you know
five days from now if you want to do a
cleanup and so that begs the next
question and that's something I'm going
to talk about in this so so in this
series what I'm going to do I'm just
going to write some of these things out
here so we are going to derive
numerical schemes
numerical schemes
uh
to construct these trajectories to
approximate these trajectories to
approximate
to approximate
uh kind of X at some next time point x k
plus one equals some function of x k so
if I know my position at time step now I
want to be able to predict my position
at time Step at the next time step so
let's say this is x k and this is X K
plus one I want to be able to build some
numerical scheme some big F that
approximates a one delta T time step
forward so then I can build this
trajectory starting from my initial
condition by just running it through my
numerical scheme and so some of the
numerical schemes we're going to cook up
are going to be things like the forward
and backward Oiler forward Euler and
backward Oiler I might even derive one
of these today in this lecture backward
Oiler
we're going to derive things like the
runga Cutta schemes these are really
really powerful so runga Kata
I've heard this pronounced uh Runge Cuda
I call it rangakuta and so there's you
know second order and fourth order and
so I'm going to talk about these runga
cuta schemes which are kind of the
built-in integrators in Python and
Matlab very very good all-purpose
numerical integrators quite accurate and
then I'm also going to talk about
Advanced schemes like variational and
simplectic integrators advanced
advanced integrators
these numerical Miracle schemes are
called integrators because we are kind
of integrating you know this D X DT
we're integrating it in time to time
Step It Forward so then I'll talk about
Advanced integrators for chaotic systems
for chaos for let's just say for chaos
for chaotic systems because for chaotic
systems you need a little bit more
specialized Machinery okay so that's one
thing we're going to do is we're
actually going to derive these different
schemes kind of starting with the very
very simplest then getting to kind of
the all-purpose integrators and then
getting into some Advanced integrators
if you really really need Advanced
capabilities for integrating these
trajectories for these schemes we're
going to talk about specific properties
like error properties we're going to
look at the error and we're going to
look at stability
stability
and specifically I'm mostly going to
look at the error and stability
properties of these simple Euler and
rangakata schemes but that's going to
build our intuition for more generalized
integrators that you might come into
contact with later in your in your
research or in your work so for all of
these schemes we need to be concerned
with how accurate is this scheme if I
assume that I have a good estimate of f
how accurate you know what is the error
for each of these schemes and what is
the stability will these actually you
know are these going to Faithfully
reproduce my my trajectory or is my
forward Oiler sometimes going to diverge
if I use too big of a Time step that
definitely happens and I'm going to tell
you why that happens okay so these are
you know probably going to be four or
five or six lectures building on on this
kind of overview lecture maybe I'll have
a whole series you know that I'll add to
occasionally because I actually do a lot
of work in this numerical integration
world
um good other things that we care about
that I want to tell you about is
I like this oil spill example because I
think it's pretty intuitive to think
about what if or maybe maybe my Lifeboat
example maybe uh you know I get lost at
sea and there's some report that I was
missing you know sometime around 3 P.M
on Saturday on this beach okay some
beach here
and So based on that information there
is some uncertainty in my initial
condition and my initial time and so if
I have a little bit of an uncertainty
here so I don't know exactly what my
initial condition is but I have some
little maybe a gaussian of uncertainty
or a little uniform uncertainty
how does that propagate and grow how
does that uncertainty grow as I go
forward in time with these different
integration schemes or if I integrate
you know my Dynamics even if I
integrated this perfectly how does this
uncertainty propagate forward in time
that's a super important question in
engineering and scientific applications
I want to know how my uncertainty
relates to things like my time step to
the Dynamics themselves whether they're
chaotic or not chaotic I want to know
you know for what parameter values does
this uncertainty grow a lot or a little
those are very very important questions
and they're they're deeply related to
this concept of chaos of sensitive
dependence on initial conditions and
chaotic systems you can get really
really different trajectories even if
their initial conditions are arbitrarily
close together so we're going to also
talk quite a bit about a kind of chaotic
systems and how to integrate and
propagate uncertainty in these systems
which is a really interesting really
really rich
uh Rich area
what else do I want to tell you about
[Music]
um
so this function f itself could be
the solution of another differential
equation or dynamical system so the
vector field F itself so you know F
maybe some non-linear function we call
this a vector field
it's a we call it sometimes a vector
field when we're integrating particles
through it because it's literally at
every point in in X and every point in
state space it establishes a vector
telling you how X changes in time at
that point and so it's a vector field a
field of vectors and this may be this
may be the solution
to a partial differential equation
and so actually the
sequence of lectures in differential
equations and dynamical systems very
soon after this I'll tell you about
partial differential equations so these
are ordinary differential equations
because they only have a single
independent variable time but soon I'll
tell you about partial differential
equations for how this function f
evolves in time so for example in a
fluid flow f the velocity field or the
vector field of a fluid flow it actually
satisfies its own partial differential
equation which would be something like
you know the partial derivative of f
with respect to time equals some other
non-linear function of F and maybe it's
spatial derivatives
so the Navy or Stokes equations for
fluid flows can be written kind of like
this so the function f itself might be
the solution of another partial
differential equation and so we're
interested in this lecture series on
integrating a particle through this
ordinary differential equation Vector
field but that Vector field itself might
be the solution of another bigger
dynamical system like the fluid flow
equations like the navier Stokes
equations okay so I just think that's
kind of interesting there's kind of
layers and layers of complexity of where
you can where you can zoom into these
systems
okay
um so we're going to be talking about
these different schemes probably in the
next lecture I'm going to derive forward
Euler and backward Oiler and look at
their error and stability properties
then I'm going to introduce runga Cutta
and we're going to look at you know how
to code those up what are their error
and stability properties how do we
actually you know compare those and
their properties to these schemes and
then I'm going to talk about chaotic
systems and how to you know propagate
uncertainty and integrate and when you
need advanced integrators maybe one last
thing I'll show you before I kind of go
into the next lecture is I'll just give
you a flavor for how we're going to be
building things like forward Euler and
backward Oiler
Point already have a pretty good idea
um of how to do this what we're going to
do
is essentially we're going to take this
differential equation x dot equals f of
x and for now we're going to drop the
function of T and I'm just going to say
it's x dot equals f of x and we're going
to assume that F doesn't change in time
just to make my life easier but all of
this applies to time varying Vector
fields
we're going to do is we're going to take
our DX
DT and again remember that this is
approximately equal to this finite
difference derivative that I showed you
in the last few lectures so
um
what I can do is I can say that my
derivative is you know so this is x dot
that's approximately equal
let me let me uh yeah so at some time T
at some time T the derivative of x of T
at some time T is going to be X at time
t plus delta T
minus X at time T divided by delta T we
know that there's some error associated
with this we can look at the Taylor
series of this expression plug it in and
figure out how much error there is so
this is really only approximately equal
to this
but we can use this approximation if we
have a small enough delta T and we can
set that equal to f of x at T
okay and so based on this expression I
can now solve for x at my next time step
in terms of X at my current time step so
I get X at t plus delta T is
approximately equal to again this is
only approximately equal to the right
hand side because this is an
approximation of x dot so X of t plus
delta T is approximately equal
I multiply both sides by delta T I add X
of T and I get X of t
plus Delta t f
of X of T okay and so this is the
simplest possible numerical integrator
to take if I have exit time now I can
step it forward and get X at 1 delta T
in the future
so this is my forward Euler scheme this
is
forward Euler
because Euler developed this and looked
at these properties for forward Euler
what I want here which is to build a
trajectory if I have exit time 0 I can
step that forward and get x one time
step in the future at Exit time one if I
have exit time one you know at one delta
T
then I have exit delta T and I have f of
x at delta T I can get f of x at 2 delta
T and if I have f of x if I have X at 2
delta T I can get X at 3 delta T and 4
delta T and I can step that forward and
build this integrator so this is that
big f of x k that I was talking about
over here and so sometimes you're going
to see us write this as you know X at
time step K plus 1 1 delta T in the
future is equal to my current
time step exit my current time step plus
Delta t f of x at my current time step
and the way we would interpret these
subscripts is this means I'm at time t k
or time K delta T and so if I want to
write this out long form I would say
this is X
at time
X at time t
K plus delta T that's time K plus 1 is
TK plus another delta T
equals x at time t k
plus Delta t f of x at time t k
okay so that's how you can kind of go
back and forth between these subscript
K's and some time uh some absolute
actual clock time TK okay the K time
that I'm keeping track of and so this is
going to be the name of the game for
this whole lecture series for forward or
backward oil or second order fourth
order runga and these Advanced schemes
it's super super simple at the heart
what we're going to do is we're going to
approximate DX DT using some some type
of finite difference derivative scheme
and we're going to to use that we're
going to set that equal to f of x and
we're going to build a scheme to predict
x one time step in the future based on X
now okay so that's all coming up I'm
going to derive all of these look at
their error and stability and we're
going to start integrating starting with
simple systems we're going to integrate
like you know
a mass on a spring with a damper so
we'll go back to our kind of trusty
canonical spring Mass damper we'll
integrate a non-linear pendulum with a
large amplitude so it's not going to
we're not just going to use the small
angle approximation anymore so a large
amplitude pendulum and then we're going
to move into chaotic systems like the
lorenza tractor let's see if I can draw
my my lorenza tractor
we'll get into chaotic systems like the
butterfly attractor and like the double
pendulum so the single pendulum is
deterministic and it gives you a
Clockwork of periodic motion but the
double pendulum where I have a single
pendulum attached to another pendulum
these are both chaotic systems so we're
going to build these integrators and
test them out on all of these
interesting systems that's all coming up
in the next let's say five six lectures
I'm looking forward to it I hope you are
this is going to be kind of the
culmination of what we've talked about
in ordinary differential equations we're
going to use our intuition for the error
analysis we're going to use eigenvalues
and eigenvectors to understand stability
of these schemes and then we're going to
take this into the next level of really
applying this to hard real-world fully
non-linear systems uh that's all coming
up all right thank you
[Music]